realizaremos algunos ejercicios que
involucren desplazamiento velocidad
tiempo rapidez o distancia benito corre
a una velocidad constante de 3 metros
por segundo al este
cuánto tiempo le tomará recorrer 720
metros tenemos aquí la magnitud 3 metros
por segundo al este esta es una cantidad
de vectorial porque nos han dado la
magnitud pero también nos dan la
dirección al este y nos preguntan cuánto
tiempo recorrer a 720 metros
aquí recordemos algunas cosas y
resolveré la versión escalar y la
versión vectorial lo resolveremos de
ambas maneras si nos fijamos sólo en la
magnitud la rapidez
es igual a la distancia entre el tiempo
aunque en realidad es el cambio en el
tiempo pero está implícito cuando
escribimos t la parte escalar que nos
dicen en el problema es la rapidez tres
metros por segundo también nos dan la
distancia y nos piden encontrar el
tiempo la distancia es de 720 metros en
las versiones caras de esto cuando no
nos interesa la dirección tenemos que
son 3 metros por segundo igual a 720
metros entre el tiempo multiplicamos
ambos lados por el tiempo esto de aquí
se cancela nos queda 3 metros por
segundo por el tiempo igual a 720 metros
esto tiene sentido al menos desde el
punto de vista de las unidades ya que el
tiempo estar en segundos que se cancelan
con los segundos de aquí abajo y nos
quedarán metros si queremos el tiempo
tenemos que dividir ambos lados
entre tres metros por segundo se van
estos tres metros por segundo con estos
de abajo y nos queda que el tiempo es
igual a 720 metros
de tres metros por segundo esta es igual
a 720 entre 3 x las unidades que es
metros por el inverso de las unidades
que están dividiendo que es segundos
entre metros de manera que estos metros
se cancelan con estos y usamos la
calculadora para esta operación 720
entre 3 y nos queda que eso es igual a
240 algo que quiero que quede claro es
que estas fórmulas que en las clases de
física a veces se muestran todas en
realidad son manipulaciones algebraicas
de la misma por lo que no deben
memorizar las solo recordar que pueden
manipular una que conozcan para
encontrar las otras y todas estas se
pueden deducir usando el sentido común
la rapidez es la distancia entre el
tiempo y podemos despejar el tiempo
desde el principio con la fórmula
multiplicando ambos lados por el tiempo
se van los tiempos y esta es la fórmula
de la distancia tiempo por rapidez es
igual a la distancia después dividimos
ambos lados entre r esto entre r está
entre reservan las barras de aquí y nos
queda que el tiempo es igual a la
distancia entre la rapidez
es exactamente lo que obtuvimos si
sustituimos distancia por 720 metros y
rapidez por 3 metros por segundo
tendríamos 240 segundos si ahora
queremos la versión vectorial la
anotación será un poco diferente porque
tendremos que dar seguimiento a la
dirección esta vez con su flechita
arriba es la velocidad es igual al
desplazamiento ese y usamos ese para
desplazamiento no usamos d porque cuando
vean cálculo encontrarán que d es el
operador de la derivada y si no saben
que es no se preocupen no importa por el
momento este es el desplazamiento y es
una convención aunque podríamos usar
otra letra pero esta es la que la
mayoría usa así que es mejor seguir la
convención para evitar confusiones
desplazamiento entre el tiempo aunque
sería entre cambio en el tiempo del tate
pero seguir usando t porque es lo que
más comúnmente se usa tiempo por
velocidad igual al desplazamiento entre
el tiempo por el tiempo se van esos
tiempos de aquí el desplazamiento es
igual a la velocidad por el tiempo ahora
divido todo entre la velocidad
esto de aquí está se van y me queda que
el tiempo es igual al desplazamiento
entre la velocidad y ahora aplicamos
esto en el problema tiempo es igual a
720 metros al este recordamos que esta
dirección del desplazamiento tenemos que
indicar la dirección es hacia el este
entre una velocidad que es tres metros
por segundo al este y todo eso es igual
a 240 segundos algo que quiero que noten
es que en los últimos vídeos ha indicado
las cantidades vectoriales diciendo al
este al norte etcétera pero verán que
cuando trabajamos con problemas más
complicados que se bebe en clase son
libros avanzados se define una
convención podemos decir que la cantidad
positiva más al menos cuando trabajamos
en una dimensión arriba o abajo o
derecha o izquierda el símbolo más
significará la dirección este y la
cantidad negativa significará oeste y
esta convención verán que nos ayudará
mucho en los cálculos en este caso tener
720 metros positivo
a tres metros por segundo positivos
indican que las direcciones al este si
hubieran sido negativas y diana al oeste
pero esto lo veremos con más detalle en
los siguientes vídeos